joining us now out of Jacksonville
training camp his first training camp as
a professional the fourth overall pick
in this year's draft Leonard fournette
how you doing Leonard I'm good how y'all
doing I am doing better for for you
being on the phone here how are you
doing this season are you one of those
guys who writes goals down on a piece of
paper Leonard I mean not really but
everybody has their their goals in mind
and what they want I mean personally 18
was but at the end of the day I thought
about the team's all about getting
better it's all about the grind and a
getting a team together and being
focused no I understand there's no I in
Leonard or fournette you're a team guy
but yeah what what what is your goal for
the season the Russian title of course
and uh really this is doing whatever I
can to make the team better and also the
Super Bowl so what is your role in this
offense I don't have a particular role
yet I mean whatever they need me to do
you know special teams or whatever I'm
willing to do it and get better know in
terms of your so have you had I mean in
the conversations you've had with with
with your coach and the offensive
coordinator and everybody else down
there your running backs coach do you
have an opportunity to have a featured
role in this offense to allow yourself
to be the rushing champion of 2017
Leonard oh yes sir most definitely mad
to have to go out to compete with other
running backs and I just I'll be ttle
for the spot okay Leonard fournette
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
at the combine were you asked about your
decision to not play in your bowl game
last year no sir not at all not once no
not one
were you concerned about getting asked
about those questions oh no not at all a
little concern at all I mean my first my
first years I went I went injury free
without what I'll getting hurt my first
two years so I mean it's immediate it
was was ever a little bit concern in my
head well just a concern that teams
might think you weren't a team player
that you you took into account your own
health at the end of a season where I
mean I mean it was a
you know my coach decision but you know
who's losing me to say that you know I
kept that between me me and coach and uh
I mean everybody saying what they want
at the end today you know well some
point prior to last season the national
sports conversation was maybe Leonard
fournette shouldn't play at all at LSU
and just wait the entire season out and
then go to the NFL because he'd already
proven everything that he needed to
prove
did you actually Leonard fournette to
think about that no no I was I didn't
think about it a minute else I noticed
you know there's a case man I would
never play this season here you know I
would have set out throughout the
duration of the season you know until I
got better but now that's not that's not
who I am it's not my character you know
especially when I put the hard work in
with my teammates man and I just want
about that is compete with him whoever
you reached out to who's done this
before at the NFL high profile running
back level to get you ready for 2017
I've been talking to Howard Dixon you
know a lot of the former running back
mr. Fred Taylor was all I talked to a
lot now and I mean that's about it
Joseph Addai a lot of the LSU guys who's
been in the league how about my guy
Marshall Faulk if you chatted with him
yeah yeah I'm having Marshall I was that
I was a kid as my father so you've known
you grew up knowing now Marshalls never
told me that
so use known you since you were a child
he's good friends of my dad how is
everything back home you know good my
two kids was growing up four miles man
this is just done be my motivation each
and every day
there's no I'm doing it for and it's
coming out here and represent my last
name representing Jaguars how old are
your kids
my son's five months and my daughter's
by the p3 oh my gosh now your daughter
your daughter lyric has never seen you
play correct
now she's never seen me play uh okay but
this year we're gonna change that right
oh yeah most definitely mushy though the
not so she see she kind of gets the the
hand of the game you know but she thinks
every football players me
not the funny that's a funny thing what
do you mean like she said if she see a
football player on a team on a TV she
said daddy but what if that that said
daddy fumbles or something I mean you
got you got a you got a correct I mean
she she was she was she wouldn't know
you know as long as she sees me on there
look like that don't know nobody does
and the game we love to play so right
now you Leonard fournette you're you're
juggling play books you're juggling just
logistics of being a professional
diapers and Disney Junior essentially
going on with a definite that's my
that's my job when I 10:30 at night
whatever we get off at practice man I go
home we'll stay home call my call my
daughter
check out my kids man and a place like
30 minutes and I go right back to sleep
so it's the same routine every day and
what was your conversation with Tom
console Mike your honour's chat it was
it was cool man
he just he just expects a lot out of his
players and especially me definitely I
did it and I at a high pick so and I'm
used to the pressure I'm not worried
about it
you know this everyday coming I heard
getting better you know competing with
the guys as a whole as a unit we getting
better getting stronger especially with
the older guys coleus Malik Jalen you
know we have Blake those guys are on the
young guys and expecting the best from
us a couple more minutes left with
Jaguars running back Leonard fournette
on the outside of his first training
camp in his first professional season in
the National Football League okay let's
get down to some brass tacks now here
Leonard where do I draft you in my
fantasy football draft I mean to me you
know I'm not really instead of fantasy
football stuff come on you know I don't
I don't I really don't know what it is
you know but there's no man uh this is
upcoming season you know this is about
it's gonna be a hell of a season for the
Jaguars well what do you mean you don't
know what fantasy football is for real
you do not you're you're unaware as to
what fantasy football underwear man I
don't pay attention to those type of
things in that end of the day I'm a
football player well I mean the number
of yards you rack up and the number of
touchdowns you score gives people who
you've never met points and incredible
amounts of
Leonard oh yeah yes that's the way it
works and then right and then if you are
drafted particularly high in the fantasy
football draft and you don't provide
those yards and thus points to people
you've never met then people you've
never met and don't really know you
really hate you Leonard I mean they
really have a particularly distasteful
dislike that is unhealthy quite they
happen to have it in real life too so
there's not going about uh uh they're
not a fantasy that that's reality okay
yes sir
all right so now uh then let's talk
about the Madden rankings and ratings
that's something you're aware of FL like
they big they kind of yeah they messed
over me on that one man let's get into
it what how did that how did this get
stuck in your craw Leonard fournette
I mean you know when I when I first did
it you know and just to me why they say
my kitchen was low you know I'm uh I
think I'm a good catcher you know
despite that I didn't really do it in
college so it kind of caught me off
guard when they say about my kitchen was
so low okay so you're catching your your
awareness is 76 your speed is 90
your acceleration is 90 that's that
those are good scores right or nothing
it to be it should be better but I guess
I got to prove it perhaps hold on a
minute Leonard maybe they gave you these
stats and numbers when you had the water
weight at the combine to take it after
holiday you know I'm 225 now man so you
know uh 225 Louis II by the way I I
would I'm going to use that by the way a
good water weight that was that that's
true how do you get how do you put on
water weight like that Leonard uh you
know I'll just drink a lot of water you
know especially knowing that throughout
the draft process who's gonna be up all
day and night just not going to change
just and dehydrated you know okay so
what time I jump a lot of water before
the land I mean I was trying to try to
use the restroom to get it all out my
system but now I can go to the bathroom
okay so now you are you're getting ready
for
week one the Jacksonville Jaguars are at
the Houston Texans if you get the ball
you get the ball you're running around
the end and there's number 99 jit James
want Justin James want JJ want Stan in
there
what do you Leonard fournette do I mean
he's like and they had a person I have
to make a mess with my one-on-one and I
put my team in the best position that I
can I thought just lower I thought
you'll lower your hat and you go through
them right is when it it's still winning
you one-on-one no see I do whatever it
takes to get that one year we might need
okay Leonard don't be a stranger
throughout your career I really enjoyed
seeing you at LSU and I'm looking
forward to seeing what you do here in
the reality football world yes they
appreciate that you got it that's
wonderful now the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that download our app please
just if it's a memory thing just delete
other apps you don't need those apps
this app the rich eyes and show up you
need that